Merry Christmas yes it's Christmas Merry
Christmas by the way does it mean I
stopped working now I started talking
about uncut gems so let's let's review
[Music]
uncut gems so uncut gems is a new it's a
new movie starring Adam Sandler but not
an Adam Sandler movies I was gonna call
you see Adam Sandler movie you think
Adam Sandler movie this is not that this
is a high paced drama starring Adam
Sandler Adam Sandler's a fast talker
he's a hustler he's a swindler scoundrel
she'd like him he works in the diamond
district he has a shop that he owns I
could keep breaking it down but
basically it revolves around this uncut
gemstone that people seem to like and
also revolves around him pawning things
that he doesn't own in order to get
money that he can then make more money
with so we can pay off some very
dangerous people and man I gotta say
Adam Sandler was really good in here
it's part of the reason I wanted to do a
video on this movie because I give Adam
Sandler a lot of [ __ ] somewhere around
Jack and Jill on it was just like well
this dude's lost it but he hasn't maybe
those comedies make more money for him
Adam Sandler steps into uncut gems to
remind us now when he wants to bring it
the guy can bring it the writing the
script the directing Adam Sandler's
performance I'll bring to life this
person that you know alright he's a bit
of a scumbag but you also empathize and
root for him actually might hang out
with the guy but I wouldn't loan him
money he's one of those guys and this
movie really humanizes that because if
this was another kind of movie let's say
it was a mob movie he'd be the character
that gets smacked around like don't get
me a drink this movie brings into focus
the humanity of someone who does very
shady activity and you feel for the guy
cuz things just don't go right for him
say he just needs a break also Julia Fox
I mean I got to talk about Julia Fox she
was great in the movie too and no not
just because the reason you think I'm
not just giving a shout out because of
the reasons you think she's gorgeous in
the movie but she's also really good I
looked at what else she's done in movies
not much actually nothing she did a
short film before this this might be one
of those breakout roles for and I like
the pacing of this movie this movie just
it keeps it going at first I was like
I'm kind of exhausted but it works and
it's important for this movie the movies
not supposed to slow down too much even
in those moments when it does slow down
the conversations as such where it still
keeps the anxiety in the forefront that
things need to start going
right or else and I love that it makes
you understand there is just no time to
rest even when there's rest there's not
rest coz it's on as mine I'm not sure if
I dig the ending but it doesn't matter
uncut gems is it hidden gems we're under
this end of the year movies where it was
like oh you soft cats here you go here's
uncut gems it's well acted it's well
directed it does a good job at giving
you that feeling of getting a peek
behind the curtain into that world I
always enjoy it when movies give me that
when there's a main character and have
an interesting enough world or maybe
it's a world you didn't know was that
interesting and it gives you that peak
that hooks you it makes you fascinate it
it gets you to want to know more and you
start google searching in the things
this movie pulls that off it's not based
on a true story but it's pulled off like
a movie that is based on a true story it
leaves you with that feeling like you
saw something very real if I could just
plead with Adam Sandler but do more
stuff like this you're good at it I will
say uncut gems is definitely worth
watching
definitely worth buying on blu-ray all
right so uncut gems have you seen it
what you think about it or what was a
big surprise this year a movie maybe it
wasn't on your radar maybe you thought
it was gonna suck ended up being pretty
sweet whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you